um christmas has come and gone but boy
one thing about Christmas will not leave
me alone and that is a song that they
play a Christmas time it is the eeriest
most horrific Christmas song I've ever
heard and I like Christmas music so not
against Christmas music I'm against this
dark disturbing song and it's called
Christmas shoes and it's a does anyone
know what I'm talking about
Jesus God Sarma's called Christmas shoes
and it's by a Christian group called new
song which I don't know why why would
you name your group new song you're just
gonna be living in an abacus telling
routine for the rest of your life now we
got a new song by who exactly what oh
[ __ ] this so so I always call Christmas
shoes and and I'm gonna take you through
it very briefly so the first verse of
the song is it was almost Christmas time
there I stood in another line just
trying to buy that last gift or two not
really in the Christmas mood oh there's
a guy in line at a store he's a little
cranky you know cranky at Christmastime
man
and by the way I'm gonna recite these
lyrics because the dude that sings it
sings it like this it was almost
Christmas time because that's his way of
saying look I'm singing in a Christian
rock band ladies make no mistake I will
lay the [ __ ] pipe into you you're not
if I get you back in my room at the La
Quinta Inn next to this State Fair where
we're playing God's telephone pole we'll
have you chanting the Sikh evening
prayer so right so that's for his bris
the guy in lies will crank it now
standing right in front of me was a
little boy waiting anxiously pacing
around the way little boys do and in his
hand he held a pair of shoes okay well
kid in front of him hold a pair of shoes
here comes the next verse his clothes
were worn and old he was dirty from head
to toe so he's like a Dickensian street
urchin in a world full of hand
sanitizers he's have you got a ha'penny
set then how about a smile
[Applause]
and when it came is time to pay I
couldn't believe what I heard him say
here comes the chorus of the song chorus
starts off pretty good then it takes a
hard left turn into [ __ ] Ville so
hang on get your seatbelt son sir I want
to buy these shoes for my mama please
it's Christmas Eve and these shoes are
just her size that's sweet he's buying
shoes for his mom
that's really nice hang on could you
hurry sir daddy says there's not much
time she's been sick for quite a while
and I know these shoes will make her
smile and I want her to look beautiful
if mama meets Jesus tonight
[Applause]
the kids mom is dying he is buying her
shoes so when she gets to heaven by the
way I missed the part of the Bible where
Jesus is really [ __ ] and catty about
people's Footwear when they get to the
pearly gates he's not getting into
heaven and those honey I'm sorry
hi I died for your sins with those bumps
are unforgivable
[Applause]
all right so he's buying shoes for
smokers woozy
here comes the next verse he counted
pennies for what seemed like years he's
paying for the shoes with [ __ ]
pennies pennies then the clerk said son
there's not enough here
what kind of psychotic [ __ ] hears
this kid's mom is dying he's paying in
pennies yeah you're six cents short how
about that yeah I like some [ __ ] isn't
it that's not our policy here at Fashion
Bug I don't know to tell you that six
cents comes right out of my paycheck I
and I can't help you and then I'm not
gonna recite the rest of these goddamn
lyrics the little kid turns around to
the guy in line and goes I don't know
how I'm gonna buy these shoes which now
it starts to sound like a scam like
maybe the kid they're just going to the
kid and his dad or going to different
stores the dad's out in the parking lot
in a beat-up Chevy Nova with a trunk
just filled with women's shoes they're
just covered in jizz he's like listen go
in there you've got a trick a guy into
buying them I can only turn off to these
if you drink a guy in the finals that's
what Vietnam did to me
[Applause]
the guy the grouchy Cline pays for the
shoes and the kid is happy and he runs
out of the store now we get to the
bridge of the song the bridge will make
you lose all hope that we live in a just
or sane universe here it comes
I knew I caught a glimpse of heavens
love as he thanked me and ran out I knew
that God had sent that little boy to
remind me of what Christmas is all about
let's review
there's a guy in line he's a little
cranky on Christmas God looks down and
sees this somebody in a bad mood on my
son's birthday [ __ ]
give that kids mom cancer
make sure he's in front of them in lines
making seven cents short for the shoes
this dial file and you'll be in a good
mood I always feel like Jesus is behind
gah going I don't think we need to get
the kids mom okay
you shut the book up who's gonna be the
best birthday you ever had their best
birthday you've ever had
Buddha gave me a [ __ ] in the hot tub
I really lost son I don't like dolphins
I'm scared of dolphins and made my wife
who was at Maui right we're Maori should
I come on baby she goes over the dog and
they're like nah I told you I feel about
them dolphin she said come on stop being
a [ __ ] let's just do it
don't call me no [ __ ] like this man
whatever now you know we all gotta come
back so you just got a stupid that's all
I had I didn't hand out no say so we go
we go we get there they got the Dolphins
in his tank it's like eight dolphins in
his tank right when I get that seat his
old lady on the back of a dolphin I see
this little boy I'm like you know a babe
I might even overreact and get the
camera take some pictures of me I'm back
in the dolphin I was high right I get in
the water I went back to the dolphin
their instructor he's like soon as you
grab the dolphin fin don't start taking
it around so whenever you ready grab his
fentanyl all right cool
I'm ready soon as I grab my dolphin thin
my dolphin went straight to the bottom
of the tank
I get down so because I was scared I
didn't let go I held on like you know
were you scared how you start to
mentally create [ __ ] in your own mind I
thought okay it's obvious that I gotta
race this dolphin he don't he don't like
black people he doesn't hit him cut it
deal with a shark bring him a black
piece of meat something bad about to
happen right so I let go I get to the
top when I let go I'm so scared
I start snapping on an instructor as
soon as I see him I was like nobody saw
[ __ ] dolphin number eight missing huh
yeah got it notice I was gone for like
30 seconds you try to kill me
man stuff I was so [ __ ] scared I like
y'all see the old lady and a little bit
but nobody saw the black [ __ ] swirl
then I know that's a black dot but
they're going around got it notice that
he's like calm down man calm down it's
three feet just stand up what do you
think I didn't even realize that I was
walking and talking [ __ ] at the same
time come to find out I never even went
underwater whatever was some water
splash in my face Hey look I'm a dollar
I was scared I never live that fans in
my life he was racist though I know he
was raised you know I know he was raises
cuz I got the water he not dogs like
idiot they've been on that like kid he
get well he looked at me he's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] what my whistle in his face I
don't play that [ __ ] you don't work
there I got him fired it's so much
bigger than money though Dave it's so
much bigger than money
oh no was bigger than money but you know
what I watched one of these nature shows
one time and they were talking about how
a bush man finds water when it's scarce
and they do what's called a salt trap I
didn't know this apparently baboons love
salt okay so they put a lump of salt in
a hole and they wait for the baboon the
baboon comes stick his hand in the hole
grabs his salt something he's had bigger
and he's trapped he can't get his hand
out if he's smart all he does is let go
of the salt
babbling doesn't want to let go of the
salt then the bush man just comes takes
a baboon throws from the cage and gives
him all the salt he wants and then the
bad one gets thirsty the bush man that's
about the cage the first place of
babbling runs to his water bush man
follows him and they both drink to their
fill and in that analogy I felt like the
baboon but I was smart enough to let go
with a song I would guess that one of
the the good things about this you had
some time off have you taken some
vacation have you gone and where crying
yeah I went I wanted to get away from
how the showbiz crazy showbiz yeah so I
decided I'd go on a vacation you know
and I like to go to hotels cuz all my
years of doing my nightclub act I was I
don't like hotels so I decided I'll go
you know my buddy tells me goes hey you
should go home I have bed-and-breakfast
ever hear tell they sure yeah
the idea is you go there it's a guy's
house and you live in his room and then
he makes some breakfast right
- thumbnail yeah that's it sure so I I
looked one up on the internet there and
I found one I went to Vancouver Island
Victoria which is beautiful guys God's
country and so I go there and I look up
my place where I'm supposed to go I have
a little piece of paper and I knock on
the door right there's no answer so I
knock again there's still no answer
it's a fine I'll look like in the window
there and there's no old man sleeping on
a couch you know so I bang on the door
right in the doorbell you know it's a
fine light here like keep your pants on
there you know pretty inside and he
comes to the door old guy you know but
I'd say 80 85 years old old Harold
Delaney was this Harold Delaney yeah
nice and half gentleman you know and so
I get in there and I says well I better
go to sleep there's no one else there
you know I'd be like a whole bunch of
people in different rooms you know yeah
there's just me so I grew up and I I go
to sleep and I'm ready to go to sleep
and not comes on the door right knock on
the my bedroom door right so I figure
uh-oh all the Harold Delaney wants to
have sex with me
[Applause]
that's the first thought that went
through your mind traveling alone and of
course as now I didn't come to Victoria
to have sex with all heralds of land
I came to do some sightseeing of course
then I hear me gotta play some Scrabble
Scrabble yeah so I say okay that's good
I play some Scrabble so I go down and he
pulls out this scrolled Scrabble game
there and we start to play you know I
like Scrabble you know so I get the
first turn you know cuz I picked the
lower letter and so I get first turn so
I make rabbit you know I'm pretty good
it's a good word and then and then I do
it better pretty quick I take like a
couple of minutes and then old Harold
Delaney he takes like a half hour like
get his word and the whole time he's not
talking he's not telling me whole
stories yeah I like hearing all stories
you know and instead it was like for a
half hours is Harold Elena go
so then after a half an hour that you
know I'm just sitting there he comes up
with his word it's a hat
so he puts it and he takes the word hat
and then he puts it like way in the
corner in that triple letter score right
the triple word the red one you want to
get to yeah sure but you can't just put
it there annoys some relation to rabbit
yeah you got it there you know and
finally gets in there but instead he
just puts it right there that's my turn
you know I do something and quickly and
then again the same thing like you know
time going by and then every word and
that was kind of good words you know I
had a sleigh sleigh ride avocado whoo
there's a seven letter word you have 50
extra points I'm still way behind them
three lamps in the boarding pass and so
finally I decide I'm gonna like I gotta
say something sure so he and all his
words were like cup and I think it was
just like things he'd see around me I'm
playing excellently I should be in the
lead but instead points behind and
finally like I gotta say something you
know so he puts a boot you know up on
this triple and it really annoyed me
because I was building towards your
triple letter and he just puts bouche
and I said if I I gotta say something
here and I go hey old Harold Delaney
there I don't know you can't put boo boo
there and then he goes you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
just took him forever and I think and
also I noticed that weird he had no
there were no blanks
you know I the blanks in the game it's
always good to you any letter sure I
realized there's no blanks in this game
and I figured old Harold Delaney must
have when he got the game figured that
that was that how was how was the how
was the breakfast this is did you have
the break was no breakfast I got up the
next day I so hungry from playing
Scrabble so I says hey are you doing
there how about some breakfast and he
goes I've never been much for breakfast
[Laughter]
like oh yeah yes I got Hannah McDonald
and pick up some breakfast or something
Harold he goes can you get me an egg
muffin I mean Kate watching 60 minutes
or 20 20 or something like that and
they're doing a story on vaccination and
I turned to Kate and I said these people
who don't vaccinate their kids are a
pain in the ass and Kate said Hanks not
vaccinated and I went ah [ __ ] you know
it so it says something in your brain
goes that's gonna take up a lot of your
time right
because the whole dynamic of our
relationship is this I I go on the road
and tell jokes to make the family money
she's meant to stay home and make sure
that Hank doesn't die and between me and
you I think she's doing a [ __ ] job and I
said why why isn't he vaccinated and she
goes I think it leads to autism and I
went what medical evidence do you have
that it leads to autism and she said
Jenny and I said don't even [ __ ] say
McCarthy don't even say it because
that's not medical evidence that's Jenny
McCarthy and I have nothing against the
woman she's a comedian and the playmate
they're my two favorite types of people
but I don't get my medical advice from
them it's one of my things and she went
but her son's autistic and I went is he
it is he really or is he just Jenny
McCarthy's kid
right
d-did we expect a member of men's that
are fall out of that woman and she said
what difference does it make no one gets
smallpox no one gets polio and it's so
frustrating when they say that because
you like crazy [ __ ] vaccinations and I
said in furthermore my mother had polio
that's true gun dead polio my mother can
work polio into any conversation you'll
be having dinner with my mother and to
go ah maybe I will have some chocolate
cake because I couldn't when I was young
I had polio
I believe that my mother secretly loves
the fact that she had polio cause polio
does a lot of heavy lifting for a [ __ ]
personality
anyway so we fought we fought we fought
and I didn't win can't win every
argument Hank's not getting vaccinated
so cup two three weeks later we're doing
season two legit and I do a medical oh
thank you I think we were the only ones
who liked it oh yeah
we're doing season two legit and the
network are trying to insure me for
eight million dollars because that's how
much a season costs so I have to do it's
what they call a studio physical and
they're insuring me in case I die
because the show would have ended if I
died or also if I got some mental
problem and just started stabbing people
that would also be a problem so it's
like a three-hour physical I'm like
jogging on treadmills and psychological
tests so I'm jogging on this treatment
with all these things I mean it's tube
coming out of my mouth
and I get off and the doctors running
something down and I thought I'd just
slip it into conversation and I went hey
it's um it's not that important to
vaccinate kids is it and she went only
if you want them to live right she she
didn't even look up right that's it are
you serious since you guys let me put it
this way mr. Jeffries I would not let my
children play with an unvaccinated child
so I thought that's all the information
I need
so behind Kate's back
and this is super illegal and involves
forging her signature 3 times I book
tanking to get all these shots on one
day which the doctor didn't recommend
but I'm a busy guy now I was about to
come home to pick up Hank
to take him to get his vaccination shots
now I knew that Kate was going to be
home with Hank so I knew that we were
about to have the biggest fight ever now
you know when you're about to have a
fight with your partner but they don't
know that you're about to have a fight
with them so you have the upper hand so
what you do is you think horrible [ __ ]
about that person all day so in case
they cry you can enjoy yourself
now no matter what happens in my life I
will always say this Kate is the nicest
human being I have ever met for niceness
I can't fault her she is just a good
soul she only sees the good in people
she'll never say a bad word about
another human being and so it's weird so
I'm driving home I'm trying to think bad
thoughts about the nicest person on
earth and it's really difficult so I'm
in my car like [ __ ] Kate
who the [ __ ] does she think she is
[ __ ] keeping the house nice [ __ ]
[ __ ] she left that plate in the sink
that was a [ __ ] nightmare I remember
that I know that was me I did that when
she cleaned it up and that's enabling
and that's [ __ ] [ __ ] right there
so I came back to his [ __ ] steaming
right here we [ __ ] go
alright games on I come home she's
sitting down lovingly playing with our
child and she looks at me she goes hey
honey hello in died [ __ ] honey me she
said what's wrong us it'll tell you
what's right thanks getting vaccinated
today and there's nothing you can do and
I pick up Hank
and she starts screaming he's won so
he's super attached to his mother and
he's like Mummy Mummy Mummy like your
mum can't [ __ ] help you now I got to
a the cars parked I throw him in I'm
doing it up and he seat plate comes out
she starts slapping on my back and get
the [ __ ] off me like that
she dramatically falls to the ground I
look up and two of the neighbors are out
of their houses they're quintessentially
watching me kidnap a child and beat up
my girlfriend and I'm too far gone now
so I just doubled down and went get back
in your [ __ ] house
Griese I got the driver's seat and I
[ __ ] fishtailed out of there and
Kate's on her knees and she screams out
fine but if he becomes autistic it's on
you and I thought but she consider that
a win
so anyway I take I cough I get him all
of his shots I bring him home
and he's definitely autistic now time it
was like night and day like the kid
before the shots of the kids afters
before the shots he was his lively kid
and then afters I brought him behind me
sitting in the chorus guy and I'm like
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no no no no no
[Music]
Kate's gonna notice this
[Applause]
and so I did whatever I did when I knew
I was in trouble I lie so I put Hank in
a baby bjorn he's just hanging off me
like he's hanging on my chest because I
couldn't let him have any it took long
time with Kate cos Kate would see it
right away you know now I know what
you're thinking I couldn't keep that up
forever
but I did have a plan what I was going
to do was right I was going to stand
near a door that knew Kate was going to
come through
look what you did right
okay so anyway I am making light of a
situation that was it was horrible man
I mean like it's nice to make jokes
about it now but if I can at the time I
was distraught I didn't sleep for three
days I couldn't eat my brain was on a
loop I so wired I couldn't I was just
rocking back and forth like you kids
artist' he could sell your phone kid or
two so anyway cut to three days later I
go to the doctor to get the results of
my physical and Hanks dangling off me
and the doctor comes in he goes how are
we today mr. Jeffries and I said not
good not good you do you told me to
vaccinate Hank you said vaccinate kid
good but this is not good this used to
be a good kid look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
kid
and she goes can you just calm down and
said no I can't calm down because I
haven't slept for three days and I'm a
bit wired and my brains on a loop and I
can't turn it off because my kids are
tickets on my phone my kids artistic
it's on my farm my kids autistic it's on
my farm my kids artistic it's on my
phone my kids artistic it's all my fault
and she looked at my chart and she said
now you know that you have a tendency to
overreact because you're on the spectrum
you [ __ ] what win you know how you
have little empathy for others you don't
listen when others talk and you don't
make eye contact
I've heard about the eye contact she
goes there's nothing wrong with Hank
he's just drugged out right now you gave
him all of his shots in one day which I
didn't recommend
now
[Applause]
it's true the next day Hank was back to
his normal self there's nothing wrong
with Hank but it turns out that I'm
autistic
oh no and I don't even know if I believe
the spectrum is very broad like 1% to
Ben Carson's or something so I don't
know I think a lot of times we were just
diagnosed personalities like I'm just a
bit of a dick
but it's weird I was 36 when they told
me that it's weird when you find out
that you're you're you're autistic at 36
because big news for me I'm gonna rang
up everyone I knew and told them and no
one was surprised I rang up me mum and I
left a message on her voice machine like
this mom you gotta call me back I have
the biggest news hour and remembering
you back and when you're getting married
and I went no I'm autistic
this un o everyone knows you're autistic
it's not that bad when I was a child I
had polio
[Applause]